how did it come to you how did you find
out about it so that night I had shows
at the stand and I was like nice I just
got announced on SNL I'm gonna go to the
club get some drinks it'll be fun on the
way to the club I was in the train and I
got a text from my agent that was like
did you say
uh the c word and I was like no I would
never
I don't say that word and then she was
like here's a clip of you saying it it
was literally a video of me saying it
and I was like all right maybe I said it
looks like I said it and by the time I
got to the stand like TMZ was there no
no they met you there they got there
before you did yeah and Comics like oh
you're in trouble